hello there reject nation I'm Greg I am
senior Erin senior Erin Alexander follow
him on social media beyond all the
fandom stuff that recover the other main
source of traffic for this channel seems
to be covering some scary stuff get this
boot and boy do I get scared pretty
easily yeah we're gonna watch today from
nukes top 5 this one is called 5 scary
things caught on camera scary people
normally it's like diving which includes
most of the people who are not in the US
it's basically scrunching through
garbage dumpsters usually behind
department stores or businesses to find
valuable things are items that have been
thrown out well in this video these guys
aren't so successful in their dumpster
dive first off they find some expired
baby food we can actually eat
[Music]
you know why we said he's like an
impaired woman or something like that
give me a little Asti squash yeah I'll
take squash really you know me get
squash squash and later that night they
find a very unexpected surprise in one
of the dumpsters there's something
underneath of that box I'm not going
over there you look at it I'm not going
over there that box right there
just move I'm not even joking
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't mess with operation between the
two Estonian urban explorers there's
more and exploring with darknet so is
this one of those rare videos where we
actually get to see the action through
two different points of view let's go
hey these urban explorers were
investigating an abandoned building that
it served as a sauna until 1995 just a
spa sauna they find some equipment and a
few dangerous others posted for then
they head up to the second floor and
that's when things start to get a little
creepy
at the end of the hallway there is a
light door with the odd phrase ghost
room scrawled on it and marker know when
they try to open the door
don't but even though it's not locked
don't if something is wedged against the
door
[Music]
that's a creepy shot how do you know no
one's there hmm sure enough it looks
almost as if someone has intentionally
barred the door from the inside
but doesn't hold the inner that's the
curtain or bedsheet covering the door of
one of the back rooms nevertheless they
continue deeper into the so called go
through
one of his friends once the Explorer
caused himself darknet that he shouldn't
continue
[Music]
but darknet doesn't listen insisting on
seeing what's behind the curtain
[Music]
did you get good
[Music]
I hope he's behind you guys yes Danna
it's like a it's like a gnarly scream
huh yeah it sounds like a tortured soul
[Music]
waiting for them
creeping around the corner Canadian
urban explorers we're checking out an
abandoned insane asylum when they
encounter something very unexpected oh
[ __ ] nope
[Music]
just let the psych ward this is we kept
the craziest
[Music]
oh that's just one of the guys don't do
you want to die please stop wow you're
actually down here
yep it smells bad don't go there this
was the creature equipped in there
something other than your person making
very strange noises cool and if you look
closely this person is wearing shoes
it's just a very skinny person within a
very bizarre way could this be a former
patient is it some random disturbed
person living in the abandoned building
that is so creepy never in a million
years never hood this next video was
sent to me directly by Kathie Lee
[Music]
woke up to find this creepy spectacle
outside their home little minutes
Brooklyn rise all over her boyfriend's
car like that at least surrounded their
house with it
as if drawing a circle around their home
for some kind of ritual some
supernatural
it was awful that a candle had been
burned on their sidewalk throughout the
night but that's not even the creepiest
part of the strangers nighttime
activities on their back doorstep Cassie
found another candle but also look like
it had been burned through the night was
a wooden log bottled-water
a nectarine drink an empty can of
seltzer water which covered what looks
like sand freshly picked berries and
flowers cups Lacroix an empty dog food
can the spoon Wow welcome that all the
stuff is laying on Cassie said that it
doesn't belong to them either all these
things also left the welcome mat that
they are sitting on now keep in mind
that all this was done quietly overnight
in the dark all they slept just a few
feet away inside their home yes he says
that their neighborhood is pretty quiet
and peaceful and nothing like this has
happened before or since so what do you
think that this person was doing
creeping around their house all night
long while they slept
why were they lighting candles and
leaving strange objects
now personally I've never seen anything
like this so if you have any idea what
this is please let me know down in the
comments a nice gesture damn that was
that second one was the second laughs I
was so scared that one's gonna crap out
of me I saw my house man that's like a J
horror movie come to life alright so the
first one with the two dumb white guys
man those are just dumb asses little
they're eating baby food
from the dumpster for laughs that's
dangerous don't take a homeless man's
food we all know this one of them drew
that conclusion there's probably a
homeless guy in there how did you like
the two dumb idiots where you kill the
beginning of a horror movie of the film
Oscar the Grouch the ones where people
are living in abandoned buildings cuz
I've seen a lot of the videos where
people are going into these like former
asylums or abandoned buildings they're
looking for like ghost stuff and they
encounter some weird subtle things that
could be supernatural in some way this
is kind of scary you know like the
animals who like made that noise it
didn't feel like you planned such like a
[ __ ] ghostly like scream to let off
[Laughter]
what's funny is assume that these guys
were going here looking for like
supernatural stuff but what ultimately
scared them away we're home
the two tears of how can you handle the
goats
we're not laughing at homeless people on
we're laughing at the fact like you're
expected a deal with like this
otherworldly supernatural entity put the
second homeless guy steps in you're like
[Laughter]
oh the girl one like she like just
looking at playing it back in slow
motion right now on our screen is
utterly terrifying she's crawling on all
fours like a horror movie they like The
Grudge like he's like a dreamer movie
why is she moving like that like but she
has shoes so she must just be surreal
homeless person her whole body structure
just feels odd like her hair her really
ridiculously skinny arms just the fact
that she's moving like that and all I
can like she's lived in the wild there's
like the hair over her head it feels
like beastly and unnatural and
unsettling like what did I gotta hear
what they said to her again because I
was so scared that I didn't even catch
what they were say yeah
how can we tell the best shoes on the
person
you barely see is having so fast the
noise then that's a diamond that's it I
don't care one team at she-demons were
in freakin adidas I don't go [ __ ] that
is a demon would you would you they have
to pay you to go in there I would never
go in there never go thousand dollars
no I know it's not worth it killed
I would freeze in pure terror he would
just be crawling towards you and I just
be good to save somebody you loved would
you go in there who is how about you're
one of your cats yeah yes I go get my
girlfriend kick it in the face possible
that building both of us on her
shoulders she's carrying this team Rob
lesser calls [ __ ] you need the
monsters for breakfast I have no idea
what that is yeah yeah this is the kind
of thing you should follow up with this
person on like six months from now to
see would there's anything creepy that's
been happening yeah I think the thing
that weirds me out the most is not the
candle with the hole in it or the mat
but the croix in the cup I mean this
person one just wants to keep them
hydrated look at it look at it aquafina
the current sparkling water another
sparkling water on top of that it's open
they're just caring about it can do
the Welcome I mean that is really creepy
that's like a very subtle way to mess
with someone Oh hundred percent that
says that's a very like I could do that
to my neighbor I'd go to any random
house and do that like yeah something
like messed up kids would do you just
like to mess with somebody in the
neighborhood like whoever's there why
don't you have to at least be it's like
set up something hidden can't some type
of camera or be far away to catch their
reaction oh yeah I feel like what's the
point
[Laughter]
oh man we won't ever know I hope we got
him okay so my goodness knowing that
every like bunch of dumb kids and then
Natha [ __ ] I would be creeped out though
I was I would think that there's someone
stalking us
Oh 1,000 I'm not gonna forget that one
oh I'm not gonna that second or last one
I'm not gonna forget that well I'm gonna
see that girl in my hallway that's to
rest to real Oh God even if that's fake
well done
all right guys well subscribe for new
stuff live she's kinda the real rejects
click that bow don't mess with homeless
people mess with homeless people if
there's anything we learn today don't
mess with homeless people or eat their
baby food or eat their baby food Hey
scuba Steve if you guys really want to
know who left that [ __ ] out in the front
door
it's Scuba Steve damn you Scuba Steve
scuba loves to do graffiti art spray
paint walls illegal stuff I know he'd
love to mess with some people and just
leave crap outside of their front door
to have them spooked the guys got
nothing better to do I'm watching you
scuba he's pledged to our patreon page
and that's about as far as he's going
right now
so what's he doing in the meantime he's
hiding out in asylums waiting to spook
people
all right Steve I had it like more
comedy to throw at you with my shout out
but Aaron ruined your shout out I'm
sorry I'm sorry Scuba Steve I'm sorry
Steve scuba blend the ghosts Oh take
responsibility to stop funny you messed
up the man shoutout he earned it
literally by paying for it and now
you're screwed his shout-out up I'm
sorry Scuba Steve I'm sorry Scuba Steve
I love you but remember Steve if you get
mad at him you're racist always use that
card
[Laughter]